i want to make sure that we're not just
in an echo chamber here we're not just
talking to ourselves so i'm bringing on
someone who i suspect is more reasonable
than joe biden i hope he's more
reasonable than joe biden this would be
david pakman uh david coming back to the
show uh nationally syndicated
progressive talk show host on tv and
radio david thank you for coming back to
the show
the the first time went so well i had to
come back for seconds i knew it that's i
that's that's why we invited you back
and listen i
i was disheartened to see that joe biden
and jen sake would not condemn
the protests at all hours outside of the
justices homes in residential
neighborhoods before their families i
suspect i mean this sincerely i'm not
being facetious at all i suspect you are
more reasonable than the staffers at the
white house now can we at least agree
this is bad it is bad to protest outside
of
supreme court justice's homes
well so d do you i suspect you want to
have a good faith conversation about
this is that a fair assessment so we can
speak freely here you're not just
looking to play gotcha here i'm not no i
i'm okay all right that's not what we do
on the show so let's see um
i this is not a protest technique i
would employ right but
i have a large platform online where i'm
going to reach way more people than
going to anybody's house so like my
personal thing is this is not a protest
technique i would employ let's go
through like legality morality ethics
etc yeah
anything that is a criminal act like a
molotov cocktail
uh
destruction of property whatever
it should be reported if there's a crime
people should be charged if you can get
ability guilty verdict they should be
you know sentenced fine very very good
in terms of
the speech aspect of this you know
there's this case from the 90s madsen v
women's health center
which found
that it's okay for anti-choice
protesters
to go and protest outside the homes of
just random workers at abortion clinics
okay now that's not my opinion that's a
decision that exists
those are quite literally private
citizens they're just like medical
workers right so
if that's okay
and we have a first amendment certainly
showing up and protesting isn't against
the law are you and i on the same page
about that piece no because in the u.s
code
18 u.s code section 1507 the law the
federal law explicitly prohibits
protesting outside of the homes of
judges with the intention of influencing
their decisions
so if they were vision has been done
though no it hasn't the decision hasn't
come out there was a leaked draft of the
opinion so i i would agree with you it's
not clear that they were
in violation of the law if the decision
had already come out and they were just
expressing their anger but because the
decision has not come out
because it seems clear to me that the
protesters are trying to change the the
course of how this decision is going to
come and try to bring political pressure
to me it seems quite clear this is a
violation of federal law no no lawyer
i've spoken to says that this is against
any law unless unless
some specific you know if they're even
if even something as relatively benign
as a noise ordinance let's say there's a
noise ordinance that starts at 10 p.m if
it's 11 and you're being loud okay now
we have something to talk about but
there's there's i i know that that's not
the law who says there's any law being
broken here that that is the law i mean
the viewers are free to go check it out
but that is a very specific law there's
also there's actually a virginia statute
too but i'm just talking about the
federal law 18 usc 1507 you can look it
up now you might say well i don't like
that law i don't think it's just i think
it's applicable here i just don't think
it's applicable at the homes of these
individuals in virginia based on lawyers
i've spoken to neither you or i are
lawyers so we may just be but i can read
the law i mean further the statute is
plain are you saying that you don't
think that the the protesters are
seeking to influence the decision
i haven't spoken to them so i really
can't say but you can hear what they're
saying right what's that you can hear
the sort of things that they're chanting
they're not saying i actually have not
heard what their chant i haven't i don't
know what they're what are they chanting
you tell me they're chanting my body my
choice their chant they're chanting uh
you know my body my choice isn't change
the the decision of course it is that's
their opinion right my body might
they're chanting in support of the of
the
ruling that will be overruled by the
dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization case
i think that if we want to get into the
minutia of this at the legal level yeah
i think you would have a hard time
arguing that legally saying my body my
choice is equivalent to saying change
your decision so i don't know david why
why what would they be doing outside of
the justices homes before a decision
comes out after a leaked expressing
their opinion i mean listen but michael
they're either gonna win on that i don't
think you're gonna win on legally they
were breaking the law because they said
my body my choice it seems very weak no
david they're not merely saying my body
my choice and they're not merely posting
some opinion online they're going to the
homes of these people that actually the
group that sent them it's called ruth
sent us they said that this is an
unacceptable attack on women and lgbt
and we need to force them right that was
the key word we need to force them to
change their views using a diversity of
tactics and we would acknowledge that
peaceful protesting is just one tactic
so it seems like they're calling for
other things but but even that word
force
now you're blending now you're saying
well they've used peaceful protesting
but they're calling for other things no
no but so they've broken that isn't my
that isn't my problem no i mean i think
that that is a separate issue but the
very fact that the organization
that's a problem as well that they're
calling for a diversity of tactics but
the chief problem that we're discussing
here is that the organization that is
taking responsibility for sending the
mobs to the justices homes says we need
to force them
to change their minds we need to force
them to not attack women and lgbt and
all of the other minority groups that
they're discussing so even the word
force would suggest to me that that they
are attempting to influence the decision
and therefore are in violation of this
law
yeah i i i'm not trying to skirt the
main point you're trying to make which i
am unsure i can identify but i haven't
seen that specifically said so it's just
hard for me to comment on it what i
think
you're pleading you're pleading uh
fleeting ignorance on this point no i'm
not pleading ignorance but what what i
can speak to is
if any crime has been committed charge
them okay i'm totally with that i'm
totally with that yeah okay that makes
sense do you think now from your
perspective
as a reasonable democrat if you were
advising democrats i'm not a democrat
i've never been associated with the
democratic party really
what are you in any party or you're just
independent no yeah i'm just independent
would you you would generally vote for
democrats i would assume
i vote for more democrats than
republicans i don't care about parties
though i see parties essentially almost
like corporations that justify their own
existence to just continue existing in
opposition to the other other party do
you do you really vote for republicans i
voted for many in there's lots of
nonpartisan local elections okay where i
later found out some of the people were
not democrats but i mean it's kind of
neither here nor there okay so but
you're not formally in the democratic
party if you were advising a democratic
candidate or any candidate for that
matter who is on the left would you
advise them to continue running on this
issue of abortion on this issue of uh
well for instance the bill that the
democrats last night tried to pass it
failed in the senate to they said it was
to codify roe versus wade it actually
went further to create even more
abortion protections would you advise
them to run on this issue in the
midterms or to back away from it in the
midterms
i so run on it i think that there's two
from a political strategy standpoint
there's two options one would be run on
the bill that failed yesterday that
doesn't seem like a good idea to run on
that um i i think where there is based
on
public opinion about abortion being as
in favor of it as ever before during the
roe v wade era public polling is now in
the 60 70 percent of americans believe
abortion should
generally be legal in most cases that
that not in every case but in most cases
based on that
it seems to me it would be prudent to
run on
we need to get the government
out of medical decisions between women
and doctors i mean and again you're i
you and i are never going to agree on
something like when does life begin
that's a different we might agree on
that you know i had a gallon of water
hold on but let me at least finish my
sentence sure you asked me about
strategy it seems to me that since most
americans think abortion should be legal
in most cases the right strategy thing
would be
we need to get the federal government
out of in the middle of these medical
decisions but but right now if you've if
you let's say that the leaked opinion
actually ends up being the final
decision let's say that roe v wade is
overruled instantly as elizabeth warren
says abortion is severely restricted if
not outlawed in more than half of the
states instantly you you've you you're
in a very different situation
knowing that the there are all sorts of
polls there's polls that show that
94 of americans reject the absolutist
view of abortion held by some democrats
there are polls as you cite that show
that when you ask the question do you
support roe versus wade broadly then
there is some majority of americans that
broadly want some abortion
uh liberality uh yeah so michael that's
very mealy-mouthed i mean
let's be honest
asked the same way over the last 50
years support for roe v wade has
continued to go up fair well it depends
how you ask the question if you ask
the same way over the last 50 right if
you ask it has gone up if you ask the
question in a way that is
i think hiding the reality of abortion
and is just talking about the decision
roe versus wade then uh sure there's
broad support for it but if you but if
you ask the question and you say do you
support this type of abortion do you
support this type of abortion do you
support then the support is much smaller
is this is why bill failed yesterday
you're creating distinctions only to
create doubt when the the point i'm
making is
over the last 50 years
generally overall should abortion
generally be legal in most cases but
work has gone up you can admit that and
still be against it no but david the
problem is the devil is in the details
because i mean i've got a poll right
here that goes into depth on different
aspects of abortion polling that i'm not
depending on how you change your
depending on how you phrase the question
if you get very different answers so i
guess my point is this
according to some of this polling very
few very few voters and very very few
independent voters
okay
support abortion
as a top policy issue it it does not
seem to motivate a whole lot of people
to go to the polls well is it fair i
would agree with that i agree with that
so therefore in that case if you were
advising these candidates
you know you might say okay just keep
using the same lines that democrats have
used since roe vs wade but if you were
talking about focusing a campaign i
think there are a lot of democrats right
now who say we're going to run on this
this is going to motivate everyone to go
to the polls make your campaign about
abortion would you say that's a good
strategy or would you say hey maybe back
off a little bit and talk about i don't
know gas prices
no no no i don't think that's a good
strategy i mean again
this is less about my opinion but it's
about what the facts show the facts show
that economic issues are far more
important when it comes to running
national campaigns so i mean no
disagreement there these are these are
just strategy questions yeah absolutely
sure there's also there was polling that
came out yesterday that showed that on
the abortion question in as much as it
does motivate people it's actually the
roe v wade overruling seems to be uh
propelling republicans at almost 2x the
rate as uh democrats so anyway listen i
know david i knew that you would be much
more reasonable than uh joe biden uh
david that's all the time we have thank
you very much for coming on those oh my
god it's over we haven't even talked
about anything we've got well i know i
think i think as i i gave you a
compliment but uh thankfully that's
missing too i think that you've
presented a more reasonable view than
the white house has i think you've
presented better political advice than
the white house has for their own party
and so i appreciate you for coming on uh
where can people find you
uh davidpakman.com i can't imagine a
more meaningful compliment and praise
than that coming from you michael thank
you
david thanks for coming on glad you
liked that clip now ring that smash like
that subscribe do the clicky thing make
sure you get all the michael knowles
show updates you can also go to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a 5 star review leave a 10 star
review if you can we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]